this video is made possible by audible
use my link audible.com /by graphics or
text via graphics to five hundred five
hundred in the US only to get a free
book plus you get two audible originals
and a 30-day free trial so for free just
click the link in the description below
this Oroku yamamoto
was the mastermind behind the worst
attack on american soil
ever that a snack on Pearl Harbor
brought war with Japan bidding Yamamoto
against the best military minds of the
US Armed Forces in the end though it
took a clandestine mid-air assassination
to bring him to heel in this week's by
graphics we examine the life of a soraka
Yamamoto
[Music]
Yamamoto was born as Takano issuu rocku
on April the 4th 1884 in the town of
Nagaoka on the island of Honshu his
father Takano sadayoshi had been
involved in an unsuccessful samurai led
rebellion against the imperial
government back in 1877 the government's
subsequent crackdown on the samurai made
it difficult for Takano to find work and
he was forced to move all over Honshu
trying to secure a job after returning
to nagar okay his wife died and soon
after he married his younger
sister-in-law together they had three
children the youngest of these was issue
rocku the name means 56 which was his
father's age when he was born
Takano was an educated man who when he
could find a position worked as a school
teacher he passed his appreciation for
knowledge on to his children the most
gifted of him was a sea rocky the boy
saw education as the route to breaking
the cycle of poverty that was his lot in
life in 1901 a sea Rocky's diligence and
application to his studies paid off when
he won an appointment to the Imperial
Navy Academy in fact his application
test score was the second highest in the
entire country for the next three years
between the ages of 16 and 19 he lived
at the Naval Academy at a Tajima city
near Hiroshima in the southern part of
Japan
life of the Academy was spartan
discipline it Sirocco acquitted himself
competently but it was during the fourth
year of the cadet ship which was spent
at sea that he really began to shine his
naval trainers quickly recognized
leadership qualities in the man despite
only standing at five foot three inches
and weighing around 120 pounds he was
physically skilled being adapted both
gymnastics and the martial art kendo
unlike most other students he was not
interested in drinking and socializing
but would rather spend his time reading
the Bible and getting ahead on his
studies in November of 1904 Missy rocky
graduated from the Naval Academy seventh
out of 200 since February of that year
Japan had been at war with Russia and a
surah ku was immediately thrown right
into the fray who is assigned to the
warship Nisshin on the night of May the
26th 1905 the climactic Battle of the
war began with the Russian Baltic Fleet
attacking the Japanese fleet in the
trash Ashima Strait the Nisshin was one
of eight Imperial ships presence out of
89 total ships with more modern ships
greater speed and better trained crews
the Japanese emerged victorious with 21
Russian ships being sunk and seven being
captured it was the victory that the
Japanese had been desperately needing
and it propelled them to final victory
however versi rocky the price for
victory it was dear one of the gun
barrels on board his ship and burst with
the shrapnel flying everywhere
he caught a large piece of metal in the
thigh and dozens of smaller fragments
peppered all throughout his lower body
in addition two of his fingers were
hanging by just a thread he was
evacuated to a hospital and did not
return to duty until August the fifth
still he was recognized for his bravery
in this first test under fire with a
letter of citation and personal
commendation from Admiral Hydra hero
Togo after recovering from his injuries
the Sirocco served on three ships on one
of them he travelled to the west coast
of the United States giving him his
first American interaction in 1908
history rocky completed a basic course
at the naval gunnery school going on to
graduate from the Advanced Course in
1911 he then spent time on a battleship
before attending the Naval Staff College
in 1913 asou rocky excelled in staff
training being earmarked by his tutors
as a man on the rise following his
graduation in 1916 he was appointed to
the second battle squadron as a
leftenant commander
[Music]
it was around this time that Takano is
tsuzuku became Yamamoto is sir aku with
both his parents having died in 1912 and
having older brothers it was clear that
a seer aku would never come to head the
Takano clan yes the Yamamoto clan was in
need of a new male heir the clan saw the
rising young naval officer as the
perfect fit
this is opting of a man into a family in
order to serve as the male heir was
quite a common practice and it was
accepted by a Scirocco however it
required that he find a wife and have
sons to continue the yamamoto name it
was at the age of 34 in 1918 that
hissing rock who entered into an
arranged marriage a few months later in
1919 he was assigned to the United
States to take up an assignment as a
naval representative he spent a month at
Harvard University is studying the
English language he then continued to
study independently to master English
while also learning all he could about
the oil industry which was vital to the
operation of an efficient Navy while in
the u.s. he also picked up a penchant
for gambling at which he proved to be
quite successful in fact he undertook a
tour of Mexican oil fields which was
partly financed from his gambling
proceeds in 1921 to see rocky returned
to Japan where he received at posting as
an instructor at the Naval Staff College
over the five years of his service in
this capacity he deepened his knowledge
of oil while also developing a
fascination with aviation in 1926 he was
assigned to the United States for a
second time where he stayed for two
years I see Rocky's two great passions
combined in 1928 when he was given
command of the Imperial Navy's first
aircraft carrier
Akagi he retains this post for a little
over a year within that time he
developed a strong bond with the men
under his command he greatly admired
their strict but fair commander
[Music]
this Iraqis mastery of the English
language made him a valuable asset to
the Japanese High Command and in October
of 1929 he was stationed to London to
act as an assistant to the Japanese
delegation to the London naval
conference of 1930 during his time in
London he received the news that he had
been promoted to Rear Admiral back in
Japan Yamamoto was given yet another
role within the Imperial Navy he became
head of the technical division of the
Aeronautics Department after three years
he then found himself back in command of
the ACOG II he threw himself into this
role disciplining and training as
aviators with absolute precision
however a months into this role he was
again selected for service overseas the
preliminary discussions for the second
London Naval conference took place in
London in October of 1934 and Yamamoto
was selected as a chief delegate he was
tasked with pressing Japan's claim for a
better naval construction ratio which
had previously been set at 60% of the
battleship and carrier strength of the
United States and Britain despite his
own personal misgivings he proved to be
the right man for the job his opposition
negotiators from Britain and the US were
impressed with his intelligence and his
reasonableness he put the demands from
his government on the table which were
for naval priety with the other two
powers this was never going to be
acceptable to the Brits and the
Americans and Yamamoto
he knew this the negotiations they went
nowhere and the conference broke up
without resolution even though he had
not been able to achieve his
government's ambitions yamamoto's
prominence at the conference had made an
internationally famous yet when he
returned to Japan he faced a period of
stagnation which was very troubling to
him in fact he seriously considered at
this point resigning from the Navy
[Music]
Yamamoto's funk it was resolved though
in December of 1935 when he was
appointed chief of the Aeronautics
department at the Navy ministry he was
now the boss of everything to do with
naval aviation in Japan this gave him
the ability to put into development some
of the concepts that he had previously
worked on these included the type 96
land-based attack plane this was the
most advanced attack plane possessed by
any Navy in the world and would form a
central part of Yamamoto x' offensive
plans against the United States now on
February the 26th 1936 there was an
attempted military coup in Japan the
nationalistic government placed Admiral
Meghani Osama as the new minister of the
Navy Yamamoto accepted the position of
vice Navy minister he sat about re
instilling a lost discipline in the
Navy's command dismissing those who
didn't meet his standards he also
actively worked to prevent the Army's
push towards war
[Music]
19:37 was to prove to be a key in the
advancement of Japan's war stance in the
wake of starting a war on her doorstep
with China she signed a tripartite pact
with Germany and Italy Yamamoto was
against the pact and he wasn't shy about
voicing his opinion this brought him
into increasing conflicts with the army
administration and their right-wing
followers he received numerous death
threats these didn't faze him and he
appears to have accepted that sooner or
later he would simply be assassinated a
crisis occurred in 1939 this was when
the Germans signed a non-aggression pact
with Russia the traditional enemies of
the Japanese on August the 23rd the
entire Japanese cabinet resigned
resulting in Yamamoto z' loss of his
position as vice Navy minister along
with his superior Navy Minister you and
I before leaving office however you and
I had appointed Yamamoto as the
commander-in-chief of the combined
Imperial fleet Yamamoto was a highly
experienced commander and he had the
respect of his men he was seen as a
pacifist at a time when the country was
marching towards war however he threw
himself into the position with his usual
gusto pushing aside his own reservations
and stepping up training in preparation
for the coming conflict by the end of
1940 the pro German factions within the
armed forces were driving the country
towards a conflict with the United
States though personally opposed to
taking on the u.s. Yamamoto began
planning for such an eventuality he was
adamant that the only chance for success
against America lay with a massive
surprise attack that would take out the
American fleet followed up by the bitts
Krieg like tactics that the Germans were
using with such positive effects in
Europe he repeatedly stated that if a
war was to be won against the United
States it had to be completed within six
months otherwise the economic and
manpower advantage of the Americans
would inevitably prevail in July 1941
the United States responded to continued
Japanese aggression in China by imposing
a trade embargo on Japan and freezing
all Japanese assets in its country
Britain and the Netherlands they
quickly followed suit the most crippling
effect was the loss of oil imports which
accounted for 90% of Japan's usage and
of course the largest user of oil in the
country was Japan's Imperial Navy the
Japanese response was to further step up
preparation for war while also looking
to seize control of the oil reserves
held in the Dutch East Indies and that
the British had in the Far East Yamamoto
believed that any attack on Dutch or
British possessions would draw the
Americans into an armed conflict it was
at this time that Yamamoto formulated
the plan for a decisive preemptive
strike on the American naval base of
Pearl Harbor in Hawaii he believed that
such a crushing blow would destroy
American morale and lead to a negotiated
peace settlement the plan was risky and
many officials were opposed to it it
speaks volumes about Yamamoto's prestige
an influence that he was able to push
the plan through to a final approval the
plan was actually rejected by the Navy
General Staff several times but finally
mo moto had to put his foot down as long
as he was commander-in-chief he told his
commanders the Pearl Harbor attack would
go ahead he then went to the naval
general staff and told them that unless
the plan was approved he and his entire
staff would resign the idea of going to
war with Yamamoto was a scary prospect
to the Navy brass and they finally
relented Yamamoto is planned for Pearl
Harbor was to sink as many battleships
as possible he saw the battleship as the
symbol of American naval superiority and
figured that the sudden loss of the
majority of their reserve would destroy
the American fighting spirit however
staff air officer for the first air
fleet Minoru ganado I felt that it was
more advantageous to concentrate on
sinking American aircraft carriers in
the end a compromise was reached the
first wave of the attack comprising of
40 torpedo planes would be directed at
two carriers the other 24 planes would
focus on the eight battleships that
could also potentially be that another
50 level bombers worked ahead for
Battleship Row where most of the
battleships were expected to be birthed
meanwhile fifty-four dive bombers with
the squating fighters were to attack the
oil fields on Oahu
the second wave of the attack was to
comprise 81 dive bombers and was
intended to finish off the cruisers with
their bombs being too small to damage
the battleships as it turned out of the
attack during the early hours of
December the 7th 1941 was far more
successful in its targeting of
battleships and cruisers none of which
were actually in the dock that day the
battleship so climber in West Virginia
were sunk while the California was
struck with two torpedoes eventually
sinking and the Nevada with a single
strike that also brought her down all of
this was achieved in only 11 minutes in
battleship row the Arizona was struck
with a 1760 pound armor-piercing bomb
the forward magazine of the ship
exploded killing 1177 officers and
crewmen the attack was a complete
success achieving Yamamoto's objective
of decimating american naval power in
one fell swoop 18 ships had been sunk or
damaged while only 29 japanese aircraft
had been shot down most pleasing TM
Emoto was that five battleships at
either and sunk or beached in the bigger
picture of things however the attack of
Pearl Harbor in achieved little em'ly
motos emphasis on destroying battleships
it was not a sound policy the Americans
were already moving towards carriers
rather than battleships and the Pearl
Harbor attack merely sped up this
transition furthermore rather than
breaking American morale as Yamamoto had
thought the attack served as a rallying
cry to drive the Americans on to final
victory
[Music]
with the United States declaration of
war against Japan on December the 8th
1941 the Japanese had to devise a
strategy to overcome this far greater
power it was decided to fight a
defensive campaign where the Americans
would be drawn into the Pacific East and
worn down to the point of accepting a
negotiated peace settlement meanwhile
the Japanese would occupy key
territories in the Asia Pacific moving
down into Australasia and the Central
Pacific Yamamoto believed that when
Singapore was taken the time would be
right to sue for peace with the success
of his brainchild the Pearl Harbor
attack Yamamoto s influence grew he was
instrumental in planning invasions on
Malaysia in the Philippines as well as
Guam and Singapore in early February of
1942 he moved his staff headquarters
onto the super battleship yamato with
singapore having fallen Yamamoto
believed that it was time for his
government to pressure the Allies for
peace its lack of action on this greatly
frustrated him despite his conviction
that a campaign that went for more than
six months would be disastrous he was
forced to plan out the next phase of the
war however his ideas were at odds with
the naval general staff who wanted to
concentrate on Australia whereas he was
intent on taking control of the Indian
subcontinent the army however refused to
back such a plan and it was quickly
taken off the table
[Music]
the first major setback for the Japanese
occurred with the Battle of Coral Sea
between May the 4th and the 8th 1942
which successfully halted the Japanese
invasion of New Guinea Yamamoto
continued to butt heads with the naval
General Staff as he now proposed an
attack on Midway Atoll that would draw
out the remnant of the American fleet
from Hawaii where it could be utterly
destroyed resistance was stiff with
General Staff members pointing out the
Midway was too close to Pearl Harbor and
too far away from Japan Yamamoto now
used his old tactic of threatening to
resign and he got his way again the
attack on Midway required Yamamoto to
coordinate his fleet over huge stretches
of water Yamamoto aboard the Yamato
personally led one battle group himself
what he didn't know was that the
Americans had broken their secret code
sands were already aware of the attack
in advance three US carriers were sent
to Midway in order to surprise the
Japanese in the ensuing battle four
Japanese carriers were sent to the
bottom of the ocean acknowledging defeat
Yamamoto ordered his remaining ships
back to base the defeat of Midway was a
humiliation for Yamamoto and he received
much criticism for it still he was able
to retain his position as
commander-in-chief largely because to
remove him would have been too
demoralizing for the men under his
command over the next few months the
Japanese achieved limited success
against the fleet around Guadalcanal in
the Solomon Islands the Battle of
Guadalcanal however was another crushing
defeat for the Japanese
[Music]
in the wake of Guadalcanal Yamamoto set
out on a morale-boosting tour of air
force bases across the South Pacific on
April the 14th 1943 a message which
announced his exact itinerary on route
to a base in the Solomon Islands was
intercepted by US intelligence this
presented the Americans with the perfect
opportunity to assassinate the Japanese
naval commander in-chief
it was a risk in that it would betray
the Americans ability to break Japanese
code but Yamamoto was seen as such a big
fish that it was deemed worth giving up
this intelligence a plan nicknamed
Operation vengeance was put into
operation with the objective of killing
Yamamoto
18 US fighter pilots were chosen from
the base at Guadalcanal to participate
in the operation 14 of them would
provide cover at around 20,000 feet
while four others formed a strike force
to blow Yamamoto splain right out of the
sky the attack it was set for April the
18th that morning that was not one but
two g4 m1 type 1 Betty bombers along
with six a 6m zero fighters to provide
escort in yamamoto's fleet it wasn't
long into the flight when the four
american p-38s were seen approaching the
bomber that was carrying em Emoto
immediately began to descend while the
escort planes moved in to intercept the
Americans but they weren't able to
prevent the p-38s from achieving their
objectives with both of the Vettii
bombers receiving strikes both of the
planes crashed however an autopsy on his
body revealed that Yamamoto who was
sitting on the starboard side of the
plane behind the plane commander had
been struck by bullets to the jaw and
shoulder and was probably dead before
the plane at the ground Yamamoto body
was found later that day it had been
thrown from the wreckage still strapped
to the seat the death of Yamamoto was
not revealed to the Japanese people
until May the 21st more than a month
after he was shot down more than a
million people lined the streets of
Tokyo as his ashes passed by so today's
video was made possible by audible who
I'm sure many of you know about already
I've been a longtime customer of audible
reading tons of books on all sorts of
subjects in fact it's kind of a funny
story I personally really love
autobiographies and biographies and
listening to those through audible or
what actually inspired me to start this
channel no kidding it all kind of
full circle so thanks for that audible
there are loads of autobiographies on
audible and I bet that if it's a notable
book there's going to be a cool
audiobook version of it as well also
related to this video there are tons of
audio books on world war ii the Pacific
Theater Pearl Harbor itself
lots and lots of those I just did a
quick search and the entire first page
of results are all super highly rated
books about this attack and its
consequences now audible was always a
good deal that you've got an audiobook a
month for a low fee but now there's even
more in addition members now get to
audible originals every single month in
addition to their book of choice these
are from some of the world's most
celebrated storytellers journalists
novelists and many others there's plenty
to choose from
there's also fitness and health workouts
for members so what of all was always
great but now there's even more if
you've been putting off signing up for
it do so no longer go search Pearl
Harbor inaudible and grab something that
takes your fancy this loads of great
reviewed books like I say just go to
audible.com forward slash bio graphics
that's also a link in the description
below doing that also helps supports
this show and helps us keep more
biographic Svidler way again get started
with a free book now with a 30-day free
trial at audible.com forward slash
biographic so if you're in America text
bio graphics do 500 500 so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos twice a week so hit
that subscribe button hit that Bell
button if you really want to get
notifications and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]
you